[Musica]
ciao
passion ti ho inventato la prima carne
vegetale stampata in 3d
gli dico un segreto per rinnovare
davvero bisogna andare a un'altra
velocità c'è una velocità questi siamo
noi la velocità dei like la velocità dei
tweet la velocità dei followers la
velocità dell'informazione che non è di
qualità e questo risulta in problemi
come fake news sapete vanno molto di
moda e se le fai chiusi come la flatter
e poi c'è un'altra velocità
l'innovazione vera si fa ad un'altra
velocità la velocità dei grandi
cambiamenti la velocità della natura la
velocità del nostro pianeta
conoscete questo animale questo animale
ha una capacità speciale e quest'altro
lo conoscete quello di prima era una
salamandra
e questo si chiama axel ott tutti e due
hanno una capacità speciale che noi non
abbiamo
sanno rigenerare le parti del loro corpo
perché noi non riusciamo perché non
siamo fatti per rigenerare le parti
nostro corpo la nostra specie è fatta in
modo tale che se perdiamo un braccio non
conviene rigenerarlo conviene chiuderlo
con una ferita e come una cicatrice e
poi cercare di evitare infezioni dei
batteri e ci sono problemi che cerchiamo
di risolvere studiando questi animali
che sanno rigenerarsi negli stati uniti
per esempio ci sono c'è la necessità
sempre crescente di organi di ricambio
però come vedete nel grafico le due
veline in basso sono come cresce la
donazione degli organi
per cui non stiamo allo stesso livello
di quello che ci è richiesto e questo
serve anche saper rigenerare gli organi
per risolvere i problemi non solo di
trapianti di organi ma per studiare per
esempio i nuovi farmaci o per semplici
analisi che noi pensiamo che possono
essere più semplici ma la cosmetica per
esempio risulta un mercato grandissimo
per arrivare a un momento in cui sapremo
cambiare i pezzi del nostro corpo come
se fossimo macchine
i tessuti umani e gli organi umani ai
tessuti animali e gli organi animali si
assomigliano a quello che vedete con i
puntini rossi che sono le cellule che
vivono dentro di una struttura dentro
una struttura che si chiama tritsch
extracellulare il laboratorio e
cerchiamo di rigenerare a sinistra
vedete un come cartilagine reale a
destra vedete quello che cerchiamo di
fare il laboratorio per imitarla oppure
in questo caso a sinistra vedete quello
che sono fibre di collagene e a destra
quello che cerchiamo di fare imitandolo
però vedete che non è lo stesso e quindi
adesso vi presento la bio stampa labio
stampa è una tecnologia nuova che
permette di utilizzare tecniche di
stampanti 3d dalle stampanti
tridimensionali per costruire organi e
tessuti umani o animali
nel caso di queste immagini l'immagine
della wake forest university in cui
cercano di costruire un rene
il laboratorio io sono a barcellona e
quando lavorava all'università fino a
poco tempo fa ero specializzato in
questo campo nel tempo della bio stampa
e quindi quei puntini verdi che vedete
sono le cellule che vivono dentro una
struttura macroscopica tridimensionale
che nel mio caso avevo deciso di fare un
orecchio per dimostrare che lo capace di
costruire qualcosa di complicato che
avesse la forma difficile da imitare con
altre tecnologie
la bio stampa in permetteva di costruire
tessuti che poi risultavano essere molto
simili al modello tridimensionale
iniziale bene si potevano costruire per
esempio modelli simili a un orecchio e
si utilizzavano di cose che si chiamano
hydrogen quindi dei polimeri o si
potevano utilizzare con questa tecnica
per rigenerare ossa via ceramiche come
questa immagine e per cercare di
sostituire parti di hosting nel caso in
cui il corpo non è capace di rigenerarlo
per conto suo
oppure si possono costruire impianti di
titani e utilizzando stampanti
tridimensionali con capacità di micro
estrusione per costruire impianti di
titanio adattati al paziente o stand
cardiovascolari biodegradabili tutte
queste immagini che avete visto le
immagini
processi che ha sviluppato insieme al
gruppo di bio ingegneria dell'università
politecnica della catalogna
però poi un giorno ho pensato e se io
riuscissi a impattare con questa tecnica
della bio stampa non solo uno degli
obiettivi dell'onu che è quello della
salute migliora la salute ma si potesse
attaccare tutti questi punti
[Musica]
sapete che nel caso per esempio gli
stati uniti il 47 per cento dei terreni
sono utilizzati per la produzione del
mangiare e sapete anche in questo non lo
sapete
probabilmente il 70 per cento di questo
è mangime per l'allevamento risulta che
c'è un problema gravissimo di mancanza
di proteine in una popolazione che sta
crescendo e saremo 9 miliardi nel 2050
ci sarà bisogno di alternative alle
proteine il sistema attuale di
allevamento è insostenibile
semplicemente non siamo capaci di avere
abbastanza risorse non saremo capaci di
dare da mangiare a 9 miliardi di persone
per cui è questo sistema
in più ha un effetto sui gas serra
l'effetto dell'allevamento è maggiore di
tutti quelli di tutte le foto dei mezzi
di trasporti messe assieme
gli aerei le macchine i treni tutti
insieme hanno un effetto sul sui gas
serra minore dell'allevamento ci sono
già tecnologie che si stanno sviluppando
per la tecnologia che si stavano
sviluppando fino adesso erano quelle che
permettevano
come vedete sopra carne in vitro
coltivata in vitro quindi coltivandola
con cellule in laboratorio o sotto come
potete vedere il caso del bio hamburger
che avete visto che era stato lanciato
in italia proprio poco fa all impossible
burger che c'è negli stati uniti che
hanno sapore a carne animale ma sono di
carne vegetale oppure strutture basate
in soia estrusione di soia che
permettono di costruire qualcosa di
vegetali che assomiglia la texture no
alla consistenza di una carne animale
però per studiare davvero come imitare
la carne bisogna andare ad un'altra
velocità
bisogna studiare nella natura come è
fatta la carne dentro la carne la
vediamo così ma dentro è formata da
fibre muscolari 11 una organizzazione
speciale che permette a questa tessuto
di rispondere alle meccanismi che ho
bisogno per vivere e per muoverci bene
studiando al microscopio si vede che ci
sono queste fibre muscolari che hanno un
ordine specifico e non sono disordinate
bisogna cercare di imitare questa
struttura per fare una carne filosa
vegetale che davvero sia assomigli alla
carne animale però non solo per esempio
la consistenza e basta o per esempio non
solo un hamburger che sa di carne
animale ma è un hamburger non è carne
fibrosa bisogna trovare una soluzione
che sia sostenibile per esempio e non
abbia bisogno di usare cellule però che
possa dare darci la possibilità di avere
qualcosa che ha la consistenza
il sapore è così senza sapore e deve
davvero assomigliarsi e la carne anche
dal punto di vista macroscopico devo
sempre sembrarci una cava un pezzo di
carne anche putin sta microscopico in
italia come è fatta davvero dentro per
cui utilizzando solo ingredienti
vegetali e utilizzando un processo che
ho inventato ho deciso di applicare
questi conoscimenti della bio stampa per
costruire una carne vegetale attraverso
la bio stampa e quindi ho iniziato con
prodotti ip piccoli per imitare come si
poteva costruire questa microstruttura e
allo stesso tempo avere il sapore la
consistenza e l'apparenza
tridimensionale di un pezzettino di
carne e poi costruito a cosa di un po
più complesso però in questo caso ancora
somigliava a qualcosa che era di un
colore un po strano per cui adesso sto
cercando di costruire qualcosa che possa
davvero sembrare e avere le stesse
proprietà nutrizionali e avere il sapore
della carne reale in questo caso per
esempio vedete sopra un pezzo di pollo
reale
in padella di fianco un pezzo di carne
vegetale che ha le stesse proprietà
nutrizionali di quello sopra nel senso
che le quantità di proteine e la qualità
di aminoacidi che compongono queste
proteine e simile nella quantità di
grassi la quantità di fibre e la
quantità di minerali e vitamine e quindi
adesso vi siete un processo in cui sto
cercando di utilizzare questa tecnica
per cambiare il mondo e per finire
volevo solo ricordarvi che per avere
innovazione di qualità per avere
informazione di qualità bisogna andare
ad un'altra velocità e come diceva
leonardo da vinci se avete un obiettivo
gli obiettivi complessi si ottengono
quando ci si lavora può invece talento
passione ma anche quando ci si dedica
tempo non abbiamo il tempo da dedicare
per le cose importanti e per questo tipo
di innovazioni c'è bisogno di tempo di
talento di tempo di fortuna
d'accordo e possiamo arrivare a qualcosa
che ci può interessare davvero può
essere un progetto nostro di vita e ci
può realizzare nel senso che ci sentiamo
più felici perché facciamo del bene
il ritardo di cera impedimento non mi
piego ostinato rigore e lo metteva nel
suo logo quando produceva qualcosa è la
frase che mi piace di più non si volta a
chi a stella è fisso non si volta chi è
fisso a una stella
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]